[Musique]
bienvenue quartier de l'épine et c'est
ici à Sylvia Sidoine ni atelier madame
tala qu'a fait la magie et puis papiers
coco fait tissu
spectacle on a les joindre
[Musique]
mais ça fait plus de 20 ans déjà ça fait
25 ans
[Musique]
vérifier que chaque tenue chaque danse
et que se garde là impeccable et puis
c'est accessoire là qui call et puis
c'est dans ce monde
[Musique]
oui c'est moi qui fabriquée c'était en
baobab pour spectacle
et puis mon feuille et puis je spectacle
content fier et puis si oui
[Musique]
de ce Lambert
c'est quelque chose c'est quelque chose
mon 4ème
[Musique]
Sylvia Sidoine ni en réalité quand même
parti au Brésil pour continuer à
apprendre le travail et puis c'est maman
est là qui a fait gamelle déco et puis
costume qu'on avale